[Music]
in pet peeve disorder news submitted by
nom nom noms man hasn't spoken to his
family in years because he can't stand
the sound of their chewing [ __ ] I can
relate to this [ __ ] me too girl my
sister used to chew it weird with a
weird - used to yeah just sounds like a
horse yeah your mom never corrected that
your mom was like oh that's nice
so she still does I don't know but at
first I was like wait what and then I
remembered that my sister you should do
that some people's disgusting chewing
though makes me go oh that seems
delicious like some people I'm like hood
you make it disgusting and if some
people I'm like oh you make it look good
well that's like those Carl's jr. chicks
dude I could eat watch them eating
gigantic burger and I'm like dang that's
time but you don't hear the noise
they're not like like [ __ ] mr. Edie I
like having food come out cuz they won't
close their [ __ ] mouths well they're
chewy yeah any other dripping everywhere
and that should be that's not that
attracts your fingers oh do I do back
I'll make a lot of noise and you go
anymore I think because I've like
conditioned do you realize like chewed
my mouth open yeah a lot a lot feel like
he would hate me some more than I hate I
just put him in a room
what's your stance with the too much
chewing I'm okay I guess it's just like
if someone's loud be like you want to
like keep it down would you say that
considered very rude a person next to me
well it's your friend yeah they're just
my friend I'll tell you two kind of loud
and kind of weird it sounds like we're a
bad enemy that's coming I mean it was an
obnoxious way then yeah they're not
doing on purpose okay they just they
just sound horrible if it's a condition
where they actually can't chew quietly
then I have a friend that she's really
[ __ ] loud and I'll never tell them
yeah yeah because it's just that they're
comfortable they're enjoying their food
and it's [ __ ] up of me to be like you
change cuz it makes me they're not doing
it on purpose today in this room right
now
no she would tell me there's no problem
talking me oh yeah yeah yeah I'm cuz I
- because I'm like I'll just remove
myself yeah from this situation and next
time I'll just remember like let me it
could be cultural to you oh I could be
cultural oh but the person I think
you're talking about even for culturally
is pretty crazy right this particular
culture I've seen them do this very
frequently anyway
well the clues are getting too uh too
specific okay okay
so man his name is Daryl he's 14 years
old from California and so he says that
he suffers from misophonia misophonia
damn there's a phobia for everything yes
this is a condition where people
experience strong negative reactions to
normal sounds like chewing or breathing
or just like any sort even like the like
a like this thing like just like all the
ASMR sounds go go drive him crazy all
dance so he said that he thought he was
going crazy for many years because
little noises would just make him go
into an insane rage so what does he do
listen to just like Taylor Swift and his
headphones all day or sometimes he
actually drills with this by wearing
headphones the majority of his day I saw
a I was like yes if normal sounds [ __ ]
with you like that hard yeah then you
probably wake up and just put that [ __ ]
on and just play white noise that's
wrong been just clearing your throat
like that yeah so he says that a lot of
people don't understand it and he can't
really explain it and it has affected
many of his relationships especially
people like he's dated and his family
worse he says you take it out on the
people closest to you because you think
they should understand he doesn't make
any of these noises like he doesn't
clear stuff before she gets mad at
himself maybe
oh [ __ ] them
that's a good question cuz it doesn't
address that in the article but he says
that it's made dating interesting at
least he could even get a date yeah so
he says that right now he has a partner
that he like his partner ends up giving
him a heads up before there's gonna be a
noise that's gonna like trigger that's
really a [ __ ] I'm gonna lose one of
those cases where maybe going deaf is
actually a good thing yeah
yeah they go Debbie's I thought they can
can he could he eat soup with people is
that Jill I like the sound of slurping
like literally any little thing so he's
saying that he has managed to have a
relationship with his coworker and in
Kurt who they've been dating for the
last two years and so he said are you
gay too
Kurt's not gay Kurt's straight but he's
gone I don't know they don't tell me
that specifically they just they named a
partner because I thought he was like he
had a family and he abandoned his like
wife and kids and then yeah so I don't
know so you're making up your own story
family members doesn't mean like yes so
no one got tied that that - he got what
the most delicate you or any happened to
be a guy yeah babies
she realized yeah he says that he'll
give him like a warning signal and then
also he'll he'll anticipate making the
noise so then he'll tell him like so he
can brace himself or even like people
around ya feel like comment oh I can't
be this [ __ ] friend hey blue I'm
gonna fear my throat like what what the
condition though yeah you're so [ __ ]
sweet [ __ ] you [ __ ] you was such a piece
of [ __ ] cuz you're so nice but yeah yeah
what if it's too much we talkin about
[ __ ] you you have a heart and you're
know what are you guys talking about you
gotta be crazy Nicky had delayed onset
misophonia yeah it's too late how like
first month - it just came like today
yeah oh well yeah that's different I
told you you have a different you didn't
just develop this [ __ ] even do it is all
I he's been having it yeah there's
another point her point is that you
would yes that you're sweet don't would
not do this [ __ ] I couldn't put up with
it
I'm a scooper fraud I'm a scuba fraud no
you're a great man that [ __ ] I'm a
charlatan
should of course a compliment upon you
and you're not like I don't want look at
how weird I dress look at how bad I
dress come on
no let's get back on topic yeah you're
right you're matching good for you back
on topic look at my hair it's just going
nuts
like always dad coax I'm friggin
ridiculous all right this one's for you
oh let me show you a photo of them
compadre Daryl Daryl big ass spider
homie
I guess the sound of a tattoo gun
doesn't [ __ ] with me because it's
consistent like that what is he doing
there
Oh working out there's the photos that
they had in the article I can't imagine
happening having uh is it this order
order they call it condition a condition
we're like you just hear sounds and it
just immediately pisses you off I can I
eat what does it pay I can relate to him
it doesn't piss me off yeah it's just
repetition a lot to me to enrage you
ah punch a radio gene they can turn I
think the frustration can turn into rage
cuz you can't firstly run away from it
oh yeah it's it's like um like something
that smells bad for me yeah like if I
smell it and I can't get away from it it
starts making me angry
that's me with like don't fart the sound
of it or the smell oh no no I could hear
it all day I don't care but like if
you're in another room in your party and
I can't smell it cool have fun yeah but
if I smell it that's and I'm like just
like oh how did this get here what the
[ __ ] that's a lot of people that doesn't
like farts Jill's opposite she doesn't
mind smelling it you just want to hear
it Oh like a silent but deadly ones
what if Casey wrecks the bathroom right
he's a hard time in there yeah a man
[ __ ] who walk in there she can escape
that nobody you don't know what you
don't know yeah you know it happened
that situation if I walk in then I'd be
like are you serious
we've talked about courtesy flushes why
couldn't you what's a courtesy flush
well because you're taking a [ __ ] you
flush it so that the [ __ ] pungent
stench
just let's say you flush six times but
it's still there
he doesn't know let's say it's getting
in the wallpaper bro you grew it in a
mule what a courtesy flush she just
thought she flushes no tits to match the
noises no it's not oh it's not no it
takes the smell away too so as soon as
you [ __ ] you flush it flush it yeah and
it's not you can smell your own [ __ ] man
the shit's not sitting there the smell
comes from your [ __ ] it does but it's
also coming from the [ __ ] that you I'm
going to say that a courtesy flush is
when you flush to cover the noises that
you're making in the bathroom oh I'm
gonna stand by it was the courtesy for
yourself no for that for the people in
them beyond area no no no they care
about the here in the splashy is along
the thing listen I don't care for that
me with my definition of courtesy flush
is when you're taking a [ __ ] and it's so
disgusting pungent disgusting me punch
it you smell it yourself that's when you
flush it and it goes away
hurry first okay yeah but I've known
guys in prison I know guys in prison
that use the same term for the exact
same thing because they're selling
they're selling they're sharing a cell
there's courtesy flushes I should be
probably right because it's that because
it's not mellow second bias
okay you used to get by that you can die
on that hill tip tip can I ask you when
you hear the splashy's yeah that [ __ ]
that dole foot that does not bother you
no I don't care about the sound what
about what about the penis ound do you
suppose you don't give a [ __ ]
the sounds do they bother me and what
wait like I get agitated though you get
like a little like do that again yeah
right you don't like that fart son
nobody likes when you fart no it's the
fart sound but I think because I know
what's to fall I could be around the
corner and if I for it well because I
know what comes out you know I mean like
you fear farts were normal yeah and I'm
like oh [ __ ] okay he farted okay well
it'll dissipate in like seconds but your
farts like to [ __ ] grab a seat at the
table and they like to kick it that's
why I must go I don't care about I don't
care about sounds when it comes to all
that stuff except for chewing chewing
sounds will drive me [ __ ] crazy I see
I can't cases are kinda chewy you don't
likes and dislikes of chewing sounds
never in there like for a angry at your
own mouth for chewing when you hear it I
don't have a saying like cuz you know
you could hear yourself chew sometimes
when you're closing your mouth and right
dude what the [ __ ] did you chew right
now
Casey takes a shift so hard he takes it
shits when you put the work yeah why
would I just check in cuz she cares what
sounds so you care when people he does
that's what they have to if I met Linda
if I meant your place and let's say your
place is very small I don't know you
perhaps you have a big place I don't
know your place is very small right yeah
where some places are set up where you
like you go to the bathroom and you're
like literally next to the person like
this yeah and you could hear everything
everything are you disturbed by that it
makes me laugh it does not make me
you're cool yeah you will not be uncool
if you say this but I get mad at the
people that run water while they do it
cuz I'm like why you wasted my water
that's called a courtesy don't see what
even though courtesy flushes is a waste
of water I understand that but just
letting it run with no purpose like
getting rid of the smell that purposes
that saved my marriage
well how are you Linda like well like I
hear it but this is one of those things
where you just understand that's just
human nature can't do anything about it
I like you yeah girl what Steve alter
smells not human nature but my mound is
I'm not going up we all know that
[Music]